Paul Rubens the legendary comedian who
played Pee-wee Herman for four decades
died on July 30th 2023. Hollywood
mourned his loss with a massive wave of
love and support but Reuben's influence
reached far beyond the industry fans
worldwide also celebrated his legacy an
official statement posted on his social
media accounts after his death read in
part Paul bravely and privately fought
cancer for years with his trademark
tenacity and wit A Gifted and prolific
Talent he will forever live in the
comedy Pantheon and in our hearts as a
treasured friend and man of remarkable
character and generosity of spirit
Ruben's estate also posted a message to
longtime fans on the official Pee-wee
Herman Facebook page where he apologized
for keeping his illness a secret Rubens
wrote please accept my apology for not
going public with what I've been facing
the last six years I have always felt a
huge amount of love and respect from my
friends fans and supporters I have loved
you all so much and enjoyed making art
for you fans flooded his posts on many
social media sites showing an outpour of
love and support for the late comedian
on Facebook countless fans reassured
Ruben's estate that no apology is
necessary reminiscing about the
wonderful childhood memories his work
brought many of them one fan wrote he
will be fiercely missed I loved
everything I ever saw come from him he
had a boundless fantastic imagination
another fan thanked Rubens for the
countless laughs posting if there's one
thing we can learn from Mr Rubens when
life or people knock you down you keep
going and fighting until the end and
another fan was at a loss for words
writing hard to describe how much joy
this man has brought to my life over the
years this is an enormous loss rest well
Paul Rubens and thank you the loving
sentiment for Rubens continued on
Instagram with fans sharing touching
tributes to the comedian one fan wrote
thank you for letting us weird kids know
it's okay to be weird you don't ever
plan to grow up do you no are you
kidding
one no no way another fan posted about
watching peewee's big adventure with a
family member before their battle with
cancer came to a similar end thanking
Rubens for his work making a lasting
memory and another had a strong
school-related memory of Reuben's
writing I did a report in junior high
about my hero Pee-wee Herman and you
will always be you will be loved and
forever missed the only reason for being
in Show Business is to impress the
people that you went to school with
Rubens brought plenty of joy and
entertainment to other people's lives
but his legacy transcends being an actor
and comedian as his kindness had a
life-affirming impact on some of his
fans while the performer may be gone one
Twitter user hoped that people continue
to embrace everything that he
represented posting Paul Rubens taught
us that we could simultaneously be weird
and kind don't forget that lesson
stories about Rubens and His Kind nature
have been shared all over social media
by those who knew him and they've been
providing Comfort to some of his fans as
They Mourn the committee Ian's death
another fan on Twitter wrote reading
stories about Paul rubin's kindness to
fans and crying was not how I expected
to start my day but here I am another
fan echoed that sentiment posting these
sweet stories of Paul Rubens and his
fundamental kindness are keeping me
going today more please
[Music]